[Music]
the Lizzie McGuire movie
sure okay I mean Lizzie McGuire was a
big part of Disney's identity and made a
star out of Hilary Duff and yeah seem to
be a big enough hit show that got some
film so why not take a look at it as I'm
sure you're no doubt surprised to
discover Lizzie McGuire was not a show I
really watched I think I have some
general understanding what it was about
though it's about a girl named Lizzie
she goes through her life in high school
dreaming about boys and being clumsy
because that's how writers who don't
know how to write humor for a girl right
and she's followed around by a little
cartoon version I think of her nobody
else seems to see her and she just kind
of mimics what she's saying so I guess
that could be interesting I guess I'm
not really surprised at the film like
God as it seems very much geared towards
girls that like to sort of have
fantasies that girls like her have going
to Rome wearing nice outfits being a pop
star falling in love with cute boys all
that stuff and yeah it does that and not
a whole bunch else exciting I guess
Lizzie graduates junior high and goes on
a big trip to Rome with her class her
friend Gordo joins her along the way but
there's this very strict woman who seems
to be in charge
played by Alex Bernstein she's just as
over the top as the Italian stereotypes
they seem to come across around every
corner but wouldn't you know it Lizzie
just happens to look exactly like this
pop star in Italy and when someone the
pop star used to date sees that he tells
her that he needs her help she of course
has to impersonate her and wear all her
fabulous clothes and be in the lifestyle
of a famous person because it's kind of
a weird reason they broke up but he
still cares about her and she doesn't
really sing her song she lip-synchs and
he doesn't want that to ruin her get
sued so she has to kind of lip-synch at
an award show it's super odd it doesn't
make a lot of sense but as the story
goes on you kind of figure out it's not
supposed to yeah it won't give it away
if you haven't seen it she pretends that
she's sick so she can constantly sneak
out and be with the boy to learn how to
lip-sync and how to be fabulous and of
course maybe a little bit of a romance
blooms so yeah
this is really not gonna interest me
it's gonna ensure as girls at that same
age who like the idea of traveling and
singing and outfits and pop stars and
cute boys and if that's your thing this
is a tolerable movie Heaphy actors once
again are over the top and the main
leads are supposed to be so likeable and
generic that you're supposed to
associate yourself is them so they don't
really leave that big an impact but
that's kind of why they're there you're
supposed to imagine yourself as those
characters the cartoon I don't really
see the point of it's not in there much
and when it is it's not really heading
anything if it was something like
Garfield where they can't hear the cat
but he had really good commentary that'd
be one thing or if it was something like
inside-out where the reactions were so
big and so over-the-top and so funny
that would be something but it's just
kind of a dr. cats version of her
screaming or saying something that she
already said I guess as a little kid I
would like that but there's not really a
lot of it anyway so I don't really see
the point outside of they do it in the
show every once in a while there's a
small giggle like I really enjoy it when
she's trying on these different dresses
that kind of look Lady Gaga ish and I
don't even know if Lady Gaga was around
yet so and maybe it was ahead of its
time the little brother is so determined
to constantly make her look bad that
sometimes that gets a little bit of a
laugh out of me too but outside of that
there's really not much else there is
kind of a nice surprise about one of the
characters at the end that I will admit
I didn't see coming and I do enjoy it
when those kinds of things happen but
they don't know if that's really enough
to recommend an entire movie for that
the film seems made just for fans of
Lizzie McGuire and I guess that makes
sense she can't really fault it for that
it's given the audience exactly what it
wants
I do wish there was more clever
commentary with the inner thoughts of
the cartoon or maybe more about growing
up and what it's like to travel in
different cultures and such but honestly
I wasn't really expecting to get that
and I don't think anyone else is either
if you're not a Lizzie McGuire fan this
isn't gonna sway you but if you enjoy
watching the show I get a feeling you'll
like this fine there's pretty shots of
Rome a good lesson here there it's not
bad it's just forgettable on generic
yeah unless you grew up with Lizzie
McGuire in which case I'm sure he's
giving you exactly what you like if you
like the show check it out if not go
watch inside out
[Music]
[Laughter]
you